welcome today we very much appreciate
John McKay coming here to Cher's
perspective on conscious capitalism this
is a busy man as you know in last year
Whole Foods merged with Wild Oats the
good news is that this merger might
finally bring a store to our region well
Milford the bad news is that the FTC
tried to block this merger and it's
remarkable that of all the mergers the
Bush administration might have gone
against Wrigley's Mars they decide to
pick on the one grocer extending its
footprint by buying a poorly run nearly
failing Wild Oats most CEOs would have
folded at that point but John fought the
law and so far it looks like he's won
but stay tuned there's good news bad
news here the good news is that he's a
hundred percent in the right his main
competitors aren't other organic grocers
but grocery selling organic food and
what that means is Walmart is his
competitor that's also the bad news
people have discovered the secret that
organic food not only tastes better is
better for you but also is more
profitable and so now he has to compete
with Walmart and that's a that's a tough
business not one that I envy for anyone
i'm still a believer and an investor in
what is typically a low-margin high
turnover business Whole Foods is one of
the only 14 companies to be in the
fortune magazine's hundred best places
to work for all eleven years that
they've actually compiled this list when
it comes to good governance Whole Foods
has the foresight to choose one of our
alums a Linda Mason for their board of
directors and their stores continued to
lighten me as they achieve what
Starbucks is called the third place I
actually look forward to going grocery
shopping and that's not just because
they get to do a shelf check
what I most appreciates about Whole
Foods is that they are the most open to
new ideas and a source of innovation for
the whole foods industry as we teach in
the innovator course it's difficult
almost impossible to create a large
organization that's open to new ideas a
little over 11 years ago my partner in
Seth som classmate Seth Goldman met with
Mike Sienna the mid-atlantic Whole Foods
buyer we thought that there should be a
market for great tasting healthy ready
to drink iced tea that tasted like tea
not liquid candy and fortunately they
agreed Seth brought the thermos and this
is actually the real thermos with him
filled with home brewed iced tea in the
trunk washed off a Snapple bottle
slapped on a hand-painted label and did
the demo the buyer bought a truck and
then we had to figure out how to make it
but without that order I doubt we'd be
in business today so thank you John for
having built an institution that has
made such a positive difference in so
many of our lives we're all ears
okay of course it'd be easier to compete
with Walmart if Barry wasn't selling
tone anyway we are trying to settle with
the FTC right now I don't know if we
it's very difficult to win when you're
finding a federal government they have
basically unlimited funds which they
take from you through taxes so hopefully
they'll be an announcement on that
within the next couple of weeks I think
this is like an hour presentation and
I'm trying to cram in a 30 minutes so I
am going to talk pretty rapidly because
I know we want to save as much time for
questions as possible I think I predict
some day we get the perspective of dip
time and distance that historians are
going to look back on the 20th century
they're going to seen that there was a
great battle that was fought between
capitalism and socialism and they will
see the capitalism won that battle it
works better unfortunately it did not
capture the minds of the intellectuals
are the hearts of the people capitalism
is not loved it is not trusted and
neither of corporations corporations are
the most influential institutions in the
world and yet how are they widely
perceived as greedy selfish exploitative
basically interested only in the bottom
line I also believe that the
anti-globalization movement that we find
today is really an anti corporation
movement people don't like corporations
and their Freight corporations are
trying to take over the world I found it
fascinating although of course bad for
business this financial crisis and the
recession some say even depression that
we might be entering into is blamed on
greedy corporations
and as if greed we're somehow or another
recently invented that it didn't exist
prior to this latest downturn rather
than where I think the true blame lies
which is on bad government regulations
which have set up the wrong incentives
and terrible monetary policies which
have have gun the money supply and led
to the massive increase in depth with
God but whether how have you stand on
the issues of the day I think we can all
agree that corporations and capitalism
have a serious branding problem in the
world today that and it looks to me like
we're sort of taking a step back towards
towards a more socialistic worldview and
I want to propose that instead that we
could have in the 21st century an
alternative to either traditional
capitalism or conscious capitalism which
which I call conscious capitalism and
basically founded on three basic
principles first that the enterprise has
a deeper purpose beyond maximizing
profits and shareholder value second
that the enterprise can be managed to
optimize value for all of the major
stakeholders in the organization and
third that servant leadership to the
enterprise into at stake holders as
opposed to what we typically find in
corporations self centered leadership
where the executives try to get out as
much as they can get it's interesting
the times that we're in to step back
from in and ask ourselves the question
that what's the purpose of a business
and if you ask that question do most
people average person on the street
they'll say what's the purpose of
business to make money duh that's the
purpose of business and yet if we ask
that same question about what's the
purpose of a doctor we don't get the
answer duh to make money no doctors
their purpose is to heal the sick if we
ask what the purpose of a teacher is
it's not to earn a living it's to
educate people I think is is a Yale
found in those principles and the
professor's here are trying to educate
the next generation if we ask the
question what's the purpose in architect
design buildings we can ask that
question of NT any particular profession
we've got and you will not come up with
to maximize profits even if you ask that
question about lawyers they would tell
you that of course they're promoting
justice and and make sure that justice
and fairness is in our society so why do
we think a business as its purpose is to
maximize profits and shareholder value I
would submit that's largely a myth that
I have known many many many
entrepreneurs and I have yet to meet an
entrepreneur who I have ever told me
that they started their business because
they just wanted to make as much money
as possible actually that's not true
Wayne heisting at once told me that's
where I started as businesses but I did
ask I've got to meet Bill Gates fairly
recently asked you know I was talking to
him about it and he wanted to he had a
vision of just putting personal
computers on every desktop and having
the best software in the world and the
entrepreneurs start their businesses for
a variety of reasons but generally it's
about passion it's about something they
deeply care about and that what they
want to do in the world and so it raises
the question who defines what the
purpose of any business is and I'll
submit its the entrepreneur who creates
the business who initially defines what
the purpose of that business is in
today's society the entrepreneurs that
will be in the 21st century but an
entrepreneur's of the conscious business
there are also entrepreneurs of meaning
that is one of the most important
because they do is they define the
purpose and meaning of the enterprise
that they create now what's been
fascinating i started the company 30
years ago over 30 years ago and i've
watched the purpose evolve because when
Renee and I started it we just had fuzzy
concepts of it yeah we want to sell
healthy food and earn a living and and
help people eat better and the purpose
has deepened and it's it's broadened
over time and what I find fascinating is
that it's evolved it's evolved because
of the input we've done from all of our
stakeholders that at Whole Foods
customers are helping us evolve our
purpose the team members are the
suppliers are the communities that we do
business and they all have a stake in
the business and they are all helping us
evolve our purpose and i believe that
businesses will flourish best over the
long run who continue to evolve their
purpose I also believe that grates
companies have great purposes and I did
not originate this came from Plato the
good the true in the beautiful I did add
the heroic and there is a fourth great
purpose and those are just the most
biggest abstractions that I could come
up with but if you think of the
companies that you most admire I would
submit that probably without exception
every one of them is animated by a
deeper purpose some that express perhaps
the the pursuit of the good through love
and care a great example that of
Southwest Airlines if you look at what
their their new york stock exchange
symbol is it's love lu v if you have
talked to herb keller he'll tell you
that's what they're doing it Southwest
Airlines while he smoked a cigarette and
taken down some Jack Daniels
but southwest is following this deeper
purpose of service and care if you if
you look at the pursuit of truth if you
think of a company like Google or
Genentech or Intel imagine how exciting
it is to discover something that no one
has ever known before in history to
create a product that takes in advance
as humanity and you've done it because
of your passion for the truth the
passion to know your curiosity the great
corporations and companies out there
there are many that are following that
particular higher purpose we look at the
excellence in the quest of perfection as
a manifestation of the beautiful what is
Apple computer every product they've
ever produced has been extraordinarily
beautiful I mean isn't the ipod
beautiful itunes macintosh those are the
initial Apple 2 or appleman Apple 1
Apple two were beautiful I think Steven
jobs has always had a passion for
manifesting the beautiful in our world
and we've been the beneficiaries of it
certainly any great artist we recognize
that but i think i would argue to Warren
Buffett and Berkshire Hathaway is an
example of beauty the buffets philosophy
of investing and the way he views
corporations to me is beautiful and I
think he's manifested out in the world
and the heroic changing and improving
the world two of my favorite examples
one is Bill Gates who's often times than
the corporate villain because he was
became the richest man in the world but
Microsoft has been a transformative
corporation and we see it even more
clearly now that he's left Microsoft's
and he's doing the Gates Foundation
which is attempting to to do great good
in the world Gates himself as a heroic
individual I think Microsoft is an
example of a at least one when it was in
its earlier manifestations was pursuing
this other example would be ma
in Eunice and what he's done with
Grameen Bank in terms of ending poverty
in the world today if that's not heroic
purpose i don't know what is call this
the paradox of profits and i like to say
since when i talk to young people that
i'm now old enough to speak with some
Authority about happiness i found that
people that pursue happiness as a
primary goal don't achieve it or seldom
do that in fact happiness is a byproduct
of other things byproduct of having
purpose service to others excellence
personal growth friendship generosity
compassion forgiveness love if we pursue
those virtues one day we may wake up and
discover that we are very very happy and
the people that pursue happiness tend to
be narcissist self-involved and my
experience not particularly happy I
would argue by analogy the profits are
similar that they are best achieved in
most enterprises by not making in the
primary goal that they are a byproduct
of having a deeper business purpose
having great products and services
customer satisfaction customer happiness
social environmental responsibility and
I'll argue today that long-term profits
are maximized by not making them the
primary goal and it starts by thinking
of business is not a machine the early
economists taught they were so
fascinated in the industrial age with
the idea that you could have a petrol
motion machine that the enterprise by
taking land labor and capital and
combining them you could spit them out
in terms of profit reinvest the profits
into more enterprise you have this
perpetual motion machine but today a
better way to think of it is that
business is a complex adaptive system it
can self evolve self correct but that's
a better metaphor in the 21st century
that leadership job
today is to fulfill the deeper purpose
of its enterprise optimize the health
and value of the entire business system
and to be a servant leader to the
enterprise that they work in if you
optimize the entire business system the
customers the team members the suppliers
the investors the larger community and
the environment that that will also
produce the long the largest increase in
shareholder value in the highest profits
because they're all connected together
they're all interdependent on one
another you can you can optimize short
term profits but then you set up if you
do it at the expense of the other
stakeholders you'll set up negative
feedback loops that will eventually come
back years in years and begin to
short-circuit what you've created I put
I only know really about Whole Foods i'm
going to talk about that is conscious
business but these are some other
examples google costco The Container
Store Southwest Airlines Grameen Bank
this is a simple simple model of what I
call a conscious business it starts with
the core values and the mission of the
enterprise at the center and then
radiating out from the center like
spokes on a wheel are the different
interdependent stakeholders team member
happy the team members working with the
suppliers and the management to create
happy and satisfied customers which
results in motivated investors which
results in community in environmental
responsiveness which leads to greater
customer and team member happiness which
leads to greater profits which leads to
a never a better model would be a spiral
because i think the conscious enterprise
moves upward and a spiral continuing to
to develop and greater levels of
complexity interdependence
when I go do this talk two team members
of whole foods market i always ask then
what do you think our deeper purpose is
when i get to that slide on the good the
true beautiful a neuro 'ok and i find
the answer fascinating first of all i
get answers for all four of them okay
somebody at the company's finding the
deeper purpose to be one of those 41
those four virtues but the two that
stand out the one that I always thought
the deeper purpose was that I created it
for i might add was service to others
that it was it's a retail business of
course it's there to serve others but
what's fascinating is only about twenty
percent of the team members tell me they
think that's the deeper purpose of whole
foods market i get about twenty percent
for that and about ten percent for the
true and about ten percent for the
beautiful and overwhelmingly sixty
percent of the team members tell me that
the deeper purpose of Whole Foods is to
change and improve the world that's an
example of the purpose co-evolving that
it's beyond those of you that are well
they're probably not too many parents in
the room but for those of you are
children which I think we're all
qualified to say that we're all or
children or someone your parents have a
vision for you and for a while that
influences you and then you find your
own way in life or if you're going to
develop and of all maybe that aligns
with what your parents want and maybe it
doesn't and we have our our break away
from our parents our struggle that we
have to fulfill our own destiny well
whole foods is that way if you and
entrepreneur creates the business Whole
Foods has its own destiny I may be the
father of whole foods but it doesn't
always line up with where I'd like it to
go and evolve and I'm actually my second
talk today I'm it later on this
afternoon we'll talk a little bit more
about that but what's interesting is
that for a long time our five core
values the first five were the ones we
had we added due to feedback from our
suppliers who didn't think Whole Foods
treated them with the same dignity and
respect that we treated they insulted
them about
stuff at walmart that kind of thing that
we created a new a new core value of
encouraging win-win supplier partners
with our suppliers we only had that core
value for less than a year and the
seventh core value we just creating
right now this first time has ever been
publicly stated so I thought we've
decided that it's not enough just to
sell healthy foods that we need to
actively promote the health well-being
and longevity of our customers and team
members to education about healthy
eating so that's going to start popping
up in our stores in the near future so
I'm going to rush through how we're
trying to meet some of these core values
selling the highest quality natural and
organic foods available I think the
thing where I'm most proud about is how
many people's whole foods is now
affected in the world which is I think
in millions of people and if you can
multiply that by the impact we've had on
other grocery chains like Safeway Kroger
and Walmart the influence has been even
greater we've also shown that good good
good health and pleasurable eating or
not that those are compatible goals
those aren't opposites we're trying to
offer alternatives to the industrial
degradation of industrialized
degradation of our food and we're
creating higher animal welfare standards
which I'll talk a little bit more about
a second I always talk about the usually
the conscious businesses either put the
customer or their employees as the most
important and they're really both
equally important you have to you have
to try to optimize value for all of them
but at Whole Foods I teach that the
customers are the most important
stakeholder because I don't want the
team members to be too full of
themselves that I need to fit in to
remember that they have a goal outside
of their own happiness you know the
retail business is really very simple if
you if your customers are happy your
business is going to be successful and
if they're not it won't be and if those
of you that are going to go out and
start your own businesses some to
actually I'm kind of curious how many of
you hope that someday you will create
your own business
wow that's a lot I asked that question
in Japan a few years ago and only one
guy raised his hand I think he's
probably bounced out of the school after
I left I had we talked about the
customers and team members both being
treated as as ends instead of means and
that means that their well-being and
their happiness has to be a primary goal
of the enterprise customers and team
members are not stupid they know when
you're doing a sales job on them and
they know when you are trying to trick
them and that you don't really care
about them so you have to treat them as
an ins in it and not a means you have to
put their well-being an interest first
even if the x is not in the enterprise
of short-term best interest in Whole
Foods case we've organized our company
into self-managing war teams we did this
long before almost anybody else was
doing it we have an open information
philosophy that there aren't any secrets
in the organization we talked about
shared purpose and empowerment I also
try to we've also tried to set up a
culture that is what I call an
empowerment culture and it's a rejection
of the command and control structures
you know the command and control do it
my way or the highway that is not a very
good strategy for motivating people i
have found particularly young creative
highly intelligent people that they need
to engage they need to enlist they need
to take on the purpose of the enterprise
and then they need to be given
permission and encouraged to carry out
that purpose in their own unique
creative ways have a philosophy of
shared fate the better the organization
does the better the people that work for
the organization does and the better the
people that work for the organization
the better the company does happy team
members equals happy customers equals
happy investors some of the things whole
foods does we have open salary
information so what everybody else gets
pay
is open is open and from it is available
to everybody its transparency that
creates some Envy but it promotes
justice we also have a salary cap which
is 19 times the average pay that's gone
up from eight times to 10 x 14 x the 19
times an enterprise has always got to
you have a tension between what i call
external equity what the market pays an
internal equity what everybody else in
the organization is getting paid and the
new organization whole foods market has
to pay attention external equity because
all these supermarket chains trying to
hire away our people we won't want to
lose them to them at the same time we
have to be conscious of what everybody
else is getting paid so that we so we
have a relatively flat compensation
system we give stock options to
everybody in our company and
ninety-three percent are given in on
executives we have fully paid health
insurance for all full-time people which
is ninety percent of our team members
and other team members or can buy it
with their own money and we have been
one of the hundred best companies to
work for for 12 years in a row we made
it again this year to number 22
basically CEOs who are getting really
rich probably not servant leaders here
you can see that how it's gone up in
1980 the average pay was a multiple of
about forty times the average CEOs pay
was about 40 times the average by 1990
that had gone up to 100 times and in the
2000s it's gone up between 350 and 400
times the average pay most fortunate 500
companies the top five executives
receive seventy-five percent of the
stock options everybody else gets
twenty-five percent at Whole Foods the
top 16 executives get seven percent and
ninety-three percent to everyone else
although with our stock down so much
with the market crash that doesn't mean
anything all the stock options are
worthless
I do think oftentimes by the time I get
to this part in the in the talk people
have this guy's anti profit you know
what's he got against shareholder value
all that stuff about profit or not
purpose actually I think profits are
very important you cannot fulfill your
mission if you're not profitable in fact
the more money whole foods market makes
the better we're able to fulfill our
mission so they are simpatico and I do
believe that we are stewards of the
wealth that the shareholders have
entrusted to us profits are create
wealth the capital and the prosperity of
our society and it basically all
technological progress in the world
today is fueled through savings or fuel
through profits for my favorite slides
because it shows how much progress
humanity is made in the last 200 years
translating both eighteen twenty dollars
to two thousand three dollars to realize
the two hundred years ago eighty-five
percent of the people alive on the
planet Earth eighty-five percent of the
people lived on less than a dollar a day
now to drop down to fifty percent 130
years later but it's now dropped to
about twenty percent around the world
that has been through capitalism that
has been through business that has been
through the corporations and through
passionate entrepreneurs creating
enterprises and that's spreading around
the world we've literally had hundreds
of millions of people lift out of
poverty in the last twenty years in
India and China alone there are people
alive in this room today that will live
to see the end of poverty on the planet
earth if we don't screw it up through
nuclear war or backtracking towards
communism and socialism and hey since
I'm eating at Whole Foods I expect to be
one of those people but
we'll see Whole Foods is doing its part
to create prosperity we have been the
fastest growing and the most profitable
publicly phone food retailer United
States over the last 10 years even with
the slowdown in sales we produced a nine
percent same-store sales growth rate
over the last decade our sales per
square foot are approximately a hundred
percent greater than the average
supermarket chain of the United States
and even with our stock price collapsing
eighty-five percent in the last three
years we still increased five hundred
percent since our IPO we do want to have
win-win relationships with our suppliers
and our success would not be possible
without a close partnership with our
suppliers and our success has helped
enterprises like honesty to grow and
flourish and sell out for huge amounts
of money and
we're very happy to have helped empower
that possibility this is the most
exploding area right now for our local
suppliers is in local products and to
promote that whole foods market is set
aside 10 million dollars that we're
making in loans we've now made 42 loans
all around the United States to small
producers so they can have the capital
they need in order to not need to sell
out hopefully but also to grow and
flourish we also have an emphasis on
ethical trade whole foods market is
deeply committed to ethical trade in the
developing world and we put in under a
brand name we call Holt rate the whole
trade guarantee and we work with various
certifiers like transf air flow
rainforest alliance and new one the
Institute of market ecology to do the
labor the labor certification and the
environmental sustainability
certification and then we do we match or
guarantee that will apprise as we pay
the suppliers will be at least equal to
or better than the fair trade prices
that were set and we get we donate one
percent of our sales to hold from whole
tray to our whole planet foundation and
we're going to do over two hundred
million dollars in whole trade
guaranteed products in 2009 so two
million dollars beginning will be
granted to the foundation for that our
company has a deep commitment to the
communities environment these are we
consider these both to be stakeholders
and that we are trying to optimize our
relationships with them and I think the
best way to think about it is in terms
of the citizen metaphor that just like
corporations are treated as a fictitious
citizen they're treated as if they would
be an individual so once that
corporation have responsibilities in the
communities that it does business with
that and that in Whole Foods this case
we therefore have local national and
global
abilities now we give most of our
donations locally and we think that that
contributes to shareholder value that
there that interdependent circle that I
showed you before that it creates
goodwill with our customers our team
members are investors are suppliers to
be a good citizens in the communities
that philanthropy contrary to the
criticisms made of it is not a win-lose
proposition we are taking something from
the shareholders and getting nothing in
return in fact it's a win-win scenario
not a win-lose one we do give five
percent of our net profits to
not-for-profit organizations or minimum
a five percent some years it's more than
that and we tend to do about eighty
percent of our donations are given
locally to literally thousands of
community organizations in the
communities that we do business in the
whole planet foundation is working with
the Grameen Bank to do microcredit loans
around the world and we've only been
doing it for four years but we're
already in in nine countries and we've
just opened did one in their Queens New
York in fact recently 99% of these
microcredit loans or two women we have
no collateral no contract and we have a
ninety-nine percent repayment rate we've
would now impacted 27,000 women and if
you multiply that times their family
we've had an impact of over a hundred
thousand people now in this program in
less than four years eventually our goal
is every community that whole foods
market trades in a developing world we
want to have a whole planet microcredit
institution established there Whole
Foods is deeply committed to being a
good environment having good
relationships with the environment
they're the silent stakeholder basically
every other one of the stakeholders can
whine to you the customers complaining
about being whole paycheck the team
members complain they're not paid enough
the suppliers are always you have to
struggle and negotiate discounts and
deals with them the communities are
going to get taxes and donations but who
represents the environment the
environment cannot make its voice heard
so it's essential that enterprises take
this responsibility on themselves some
things Whole Foods is done we're very
committed to sustainable seafood we were
the first supermarket in united states
to align with the Marine Stewardship
Council and we promote their sustainable
products in our stores for the last
several years we've had a hundred
percent of our energy zenthon through
wind energy credits we have a commitment
to green building in our stores we have
green mission teams that are locally
driven and this is an exciting idea our
stores actually organize green mission
teams where team members come together
they make suggestions on the way the
store can be more environmentally
sustainable and what's fascinating about
that is the all the bubble up ideas that
occur that the local teams network with
their peers in the region and around the
company and the best green mission ideas
end up getting spread through the whole
organization what's fascinating is the
millennial generation the generation now
which many of the people in this
students here is incredibly
environmentally sensitive and they are
the ones that whole foods market that
are driving this we may have started it
my generation may have started this
commitment but what the younger
generation is telling us you haven't
gone nearly far enough there's so much
more we need to do here and so they are
champing it they are pushing it although
i'd like to make this joke sometimes
that i've been hacking away in the in
the jungle for the last 30 years trying
to carve a path out and we some young
people come up in an air-conditioned SUV
and ask is this as far as you've gotten
and it's like get out of the car and
take up the machete and start hacking
away here with me one thing Whole Foods
is deeply committed to is animal welfare
and one of the dark secrets in America
that people have not been willing to
look at is what we are doing to our
livestock animals and I used to show a
little five-minute clip in this
presentation is it got people so upset
that I stopped showing it because it
showed what's happening in our factory
farms and what whole foods is trying to
do is we set up our own animal welfare
standards and we're doing it not on an
all-or-nothing standards such as organic
is an organic if you qualify for organic
you have no incentive to improve beyond
the minimum threshold here we have a
five-step program that allows animal and
animal farmers to improve their welfare
practices so they can get up and so
they're going to be branded and labeled
in our case by what step there at by the
way step zero is what 99% of the product
that's raised in America is right now is
step zero it wouldn't even it's in the
animals are in in cages and crates and
their welfare is totally irrelevant to
the production process so we're going to
launch this program in the south in in
March and before 2009 is over we should
have it in all of our region's so look
for it if you get into our stores here
you can see what the labels will look
like on the product have I been talking
about corporate social responsibility
CSR I want to make a distinction here
the differences between CSR and
conscious capitalism these are not
synonyms they are not the same thing
this is a different vision corporate
social responsibility is a good thing
but it's not nearly enough why not
because it's basically taking the old
paradigm of traditional capitalism and
simply grafting an obligation that you
have to do something for the community
it doesn't transform the way people
think about the business enterprise it
remains shareholder oriented instead of
stakeholder oriented it it doesn't it it
has nothing to do with corporate purpose
except for maximizing profits
it adds an ethical and financial goal to
business goals whereas the conscious
capitalism reconciles a caring and
profitability through higher synergies
CSR is consistent with the traditional
mechanistic model that we think of a
business whereas the conscious business
is a self-adaptive holistic complex
system the best way though is that
recognize that traditional CSR is simply
grafting an artificial philosophy on
usually handled by the PR department in
most corporations why it's rightfully
called greenwashing because the
corporation is doing what it needs to do
to get favorable publicity but it
doesn't fundamentally care it hasn't
really transformed itself to make it
part of the DNA of the enterprise CSR
also generally tends to assume that all
good deeds are equally desirable and
I'll submit the conscious business is
attempting to make its social
responsibility environmental
responsibility part of its core mission
it's not and so that you have to you
focus on the on the social
responsibility in the environmental
that's consistent with everything else
that your business is doing that aligns
with it it's not an add-on let me push
down through just briefly talk a little
bit about not-for-profit organizations
because they have something to teach
business they get the thing about
purpose they are all motivated by a
deeper purpose that is the great lesson
that they had to teach the business
world today unfortunately they are not
able to transcend self-interest just
because they have a deeper purpose and
they oftentimes have sort of an
anti-business anti corporation and anti
profit mentality which holds them back
from reaching their fullest potential
therefore making them not as sustainable
as they could be over the long term in
fact they also
need to develop to a higher holistic
model and here's I've modeled out the
the conscious nonprofit organizational
model does that look familiar it's
exactly the same as the conscious
business the only difference is instead
of having a business mission it has a
social mission and instead of having
motivated investors it has motivated
donors otherwise the model is very very
similar and that's important to realize
because of the incredible bifurcation
that we have in our society today or we
think of a not-for-profit is good an
altruistic that it's doing all kinds of
wonderful things for our society and on
the other side of the wall are these
greedy selfish exploitative corporations
who only care about money or ruining the
environment routinely I mean did you
know that 99% of the murders that you
see on television are committed by
businessmen that's a fact ninety-nine
percent we are the biggest murderers out
there inevitably when you have
environmental issues it's a corporation
that's doing the despoiling this is how
the stereotypes in America are today the
good and the evil and not-for-profits
and the corporation's I want to tear the
wall down I want to tear this wall down
that basically this idea that on the one
hand is selfishness I win you lose and
on the other hand is altruism and
self-sacrifice I lose and you win that
we that's not a good model we need the
Aristotelian golden mean here and that
is what i would call creative love love
of self and love of others if we start
with loving ourselves and extend that to
our family and our friends and our
larger tribe and our
your company our nation our race we can
can expand that love to all of humanity
eventually all mammals and potentially
all sentient beings and to all of
existence I want us to evolve in the
21st century from traditional capitalism
to conscious capitalism from the profit
focus to the purpose focus we're only
shareholders win to all the stakeholders
win from short-term to long-term from
zero sum to win win win from
self-centered to holistic from conflicts
of interest to harmony of interest from
parasitic to mutualistic from
exploitative to creating value from
trade-offs to synergies from dislikes
and hated to value and love to not
trusted to trusted this is what we can
create in the 21st century a whole new
way to think about enterprise a whole
new way to think about business and a
whole new way to think about capitalism
to just reiterate the three primary
purposes the conscious business or
conscious capitalism the enterprise has
a deeper purpose that includes but goes
beyond maximizing profits and
shareholder value the enterprise has
managed optimized value on behalf of all
the stakeholders and servant leadership
to the enterprise into its stakeholders
is the purpose and function of the
leadership of the enterprise thanks very
much